So I've started reading this amazing
book by Richard Powers.
And in his book he says the best arguments in the world
won't change a person mind.
The only thing that can do that is a good story.
I kind of agree with that.
Because I've been working on climate change
since 02004 and this entire time
I've been talking to lots of different people.
And it's really hard just to show data and show facts
like the the slides that I started my talk off with today.
That usually doesn't change people's minds.
Especially if  their minds are already made up.
So I think stories are really important.
Neil Gaiman actually gave a talk at the Long Now.
And he basically says all good stories change you.
And I think that's really powerful.
All good stories do change us.
But sometimes we don't know how they changed us.
And sometimes the change takes place like
way way way into the future.
So I'm trying to figure out how to deal with that.
So what type of action am I trying to
get at?
We need a price on carbon.
I think all of us will agree with that.
We really need a price on carbon right now.
And so we need public support for a price on carbon.
And Washington state is starting to do that.
We need to change individual behavior as well
that reflects our new transition pathway that we're trying to get to.
And so a lot of my past work has looked
at facts and feelings separately.
I've sort of kept them separate and I've been
toggling between both of them.
Because looking at them together makes things
really really messy. So what I've looked at is
how do people understand what is most effective
for them to change in their own lives.
So if I were to ask you today,
what is the single most effective thing you can do
to decrease your energy consumption:
would you know?
Do you want to shout out some answers?
'Don't have kids' 'Don''t eat meat'
'Don't fly' 'Don't fly'
'Electric cars' 'Food waste'
All right so we have a really good list!
I'm going to show you what the modal response is
in the United States. You're gonna be really surprised.
And then I've also been looking at
how do you change social norms?
How do you get people to pay attention to this problem?
Because attention is actually a very limited resource.
So think of attention is like a very small pond of water
that you carry with you everywhere you go.
And every time someone asks for something
you're like giving them a little bit of that water.
And then you're like 'Oh my god where did my water go?'
I need to go and back into my cave.
So that's what attention is...
it's a seriously limited resource.
So I asked you this question: in your opinion,
what is the most effective thing?
Here are the responses that we get.
Since the 1980s this has been the #1 modal response
that people give to this open-ended question
"what is the single most effective thing?"
The modal response, starting with Willett Kempton
in the 1980s, has been "turning off the lights."
And this is when you ask people very broadly,
hey, what is the single most effective thing?
Very similar to what I asked you.
However a surprising finding from my work
that I'm not going to show you,
but I'll talk to you about it for
a second, is if you ask people
'what is the single most effective thing
other Americans can do?'
Do you know what the answers are?
All of the ones that you told me.
So 'Carpooling' 'Getting an efficient car'
'Getting an electric car' 'Biking instead of driving'...
So the answers really change.
It's not that people don't know what is effective.
It's that they don't want to do those behaviors themselves.
I'm telling you more challenges than solutions.
So turning off the lights is great please do that.
But it's not the most effective thing.
You guys know already.
So... given my training in physics and in engineering
I was really interested in how do people
quantitatively estimate how much
energy different appliances use.
If I were to ask you do you know what the difference is
between a watt and a watt-hour, do you know?
You guys know. Okay... two hands went up.
Do you guys know? Yeah, three hands went up.
Okay, alright... a couple of guys in the back..
and there's a friend saying yeah he knows...
Okay they're all pointing at each other.
I don't think they really know.
So a lot of people do not know
what a watt and a watt-hour is, right?
So they don't know what the units
of energy are.
So what I wanted to understand is,
if I were to ask people about different appliances
in their homes how well do they understand
how much energy different appliances use.
Just broadly.
So what I first had to do--and over here on the y-axis
you have "perceived energy used or saved"
in watt-hours.
On the x-axis you have "actual energy used or saved"
This is a log-log scale so it goes from 1, 10, 100...
so on and so forth.
So data that lies along the diagonal line
means people's perceptions match reality. Okay?
So what I said was: imagine a 100 watt light bulb.
A 100 watt light bulb being left on for an hour
uses "100 units" of energy.
Now how many units of energy
would your dishwasher use?
Would you guys be able to... kind of?
Yeah in the same amount of time in one hour.
So that was the type of question I asked people.
I won't put you on the spot. I'll just show you the data.
So I told everyone a 100 watt light bulb
uses a hundred units of energy.
How many units of energy would
these different appliances use?
So in  general the orange line is the overall curve.
But I'm gonna walk you through it with some examples.
So laptops are overestimated by a factor of two.
So people think it's equivalent to one light bulb
when it's actually equivalent to half.
And this is data from 02009, so now
laptops are becoming way way way more efficient.
Changing the washer setting from hot to cold
actually is underestimated by a factor of 40.
So people think changing from hot to cold
is equivalent to saving one light bulb when it's
actually equivalent to saving 40 lightbulbs.
So this is the entire set of appliances that we looked at.
And so what you notice is that
when you start using a lot of energy
when you start thinking about appliances
that use a lot of energy there's a huge underestimation.
A lot of this data is below the diagonal line.
Not just that.
People are not able to correctly differentiate
between these appliances.
So there's this compression bias.
So what we really need to do
if we are thinking about energy use is we need
to take that curve and pull it up towards the diagonal.
How do we make people accurate?
Then there's the other question,
which I hope you guys will ask me:
Does accuracy matter if we have limited effort?
And I would say, yeah, it does. If people think that
some of these ineffective behaviors are really effective,
and they're not that's really problematic.
So... does anyone have accurate perceptions?
So, this is disclaimer #2,
we asked 2 electrical engineers.
And they're really accurate.
So engineers, yeah, we're awesome.
So engineers do really well on this task.
And so what we did was
we tested a manufactured heuristic.
Let me break that down and what that means.
A heuristic is basically a rule, right?
So I can give you a rule to enact a particular behavior.
A manufactured heuristic is a manufactured rule
that I give you to use when you're making a decision.
So if I were to tell you large appliances
that heat and cool use a lot more energy than you think.
That actually is a heuristic
that if you're making your energy estimates
that actually pulls that curve up towards the diagonal.
So I'm not teaching you what the difference is between
watts and watt-hours. I'm not
telling you how to compute
how much energy different appliances use.
I'm just giving you a very simple rule.
So that's what the heuristic condition is right here.
So you can see the baseline basically
replicates the original data.
The heuristic condition bumps the slope up.
And then if I give you multiple anchors,
so I just gave one light bulb in the first condition.
But if I were to give you an LED and
I were to give you a dishwasher,
that actually helps you gearshift
between these different appliances.
So that actually improves your perceptions a lot.
So there are ways that we found that
actually are able to correct people's misperceptions
of energy use. Sort of circumventing
teaching people basic energy physics.
You guys with me so far?
Yeah? Okay, great.